el eugenio es el mayor compuesto
presente en el aceite del clavo tiene
una masa molar de 160 y 4.2 gramos por
mol y está compuesto por un 73.14 de
carbono y 7.37 por ciento de hidrógeno
el resto es oxígeno cuál es la fórmula
empírica y molecular del eugenio el
entonces para resolver este problema
primero deberíamos recordar que es la
fórmula empírica y que es la fórmula
molecular de una sustancia la fórmula
empírica es la proporción más simple que
podemos dar de digamos de presencia de
átomos de cada una de las de las de los
elementos mientras que la fórmula
molecular es el número exacto de átomos
que cada uno de estos elementos presenta
en el compuesto que en nuestro caso es
el eugenio muy bien entonces para este
ejercicio vamos a tener que utilizar
estos porcentajes de carbono hidrógeno y
oxígeno para poder
cuál es la fórmula empírica y molecular
del eugenio entonces para ir fijando muy
bien las ideas vamos a suponer lo
siguiente
supongamos supongamos que tenemos bueno
aquí nos dicen que tenemos una masa
molar de 164.2 gramos por mol entonces
digamos que tenemos un molde
un molde eugenio
eugenio muy bien si nosotros tenemos un
molde eugenio esto nos implica que
tenemos 164.2 gramos de euge no es
verdad
renault ahí está sí porque nos está
diciendo que tenemos una masa molar de
164.2 gramos por mol si yo tengo un mol
entonces tengo 164.2 gramos de eugenio
muy bien entonces vamos a utilizar el
porcentaje de carbono y de hidrógeno
para conocer su masa y también poder
determinar cuántos gramos de oxígeno
tenemos entonces esto es muy muy rápido
de hacer por lo siguiente tenemos 164
déjenme ponerle un poquito más arriba
tenemos 164 puntos 2 gramos de eugenio y
el 73.14
es de carbono
así que si nosotros multiplicamos por
73.14 si multiplicamos por 73.14 por
ciento entonces vamos a obtener la
cantidad de gramos que tenemos de
carbono muy bien entonces esto vamos a
ver cuánto es tenemos 160 y 4.2 y
multiplicamos por el 73 punto 14% que es
lo mismo que multiplicar por 0.7 314 muy
bien multiplicamos y eso nos da 120.098
20.1 entonces esto es 120 punto 1 gramos
de carbono muy bien y ahora vamos a ver
cuántos gramos tenemos de hidrógeno que
vamos a esencialmente hacer exactamente
el mismo procedimiento
tenemos 164 puntos 2 gramos de eugenio
pero
él 7.37 por ciento el 7.37 por ciento es
de hidrógeno entonces volvemos a hacer
esta multiplicación y nos queda 164.2
multiplicados por el 7.37 por ciento de
su s 0.07 37 y eso nos da 12.1 vamos a
dejarlo como 12.1 entonces tenemos 12.1
gramos de hidrógeno muy bien ahora bien
nosotros no sabemos cuánto tenemos de
oxígeno lo que sí sabemos es que el
resto de éste del eugenio es oxígeno es
decir lo que no es carbono ni hidrógeno
tiene que ser oxígeno entonces aquí
tenemos la cantidad de gramos de carbono
y aquí la cantidad de gramos de
hidrógeno si al total le restamos los
gramos de carbono y de hidrógeno que
tenemos entonces obtenemos la cantidad
de gramos que quedan de oxígeno otra
forma de hacerlo es por ejemplo si
nosotros tenemos estos
porcentajes el porcentaje restante del
100 por ciento es lo que corresponde al
oxígeno y después podríamos calcular
el número de gramos que tenemos pero
vamos a hacerlo de esta forma que yo
creo que es más fácil tenemos 164.2 y le
restamos 120 punto 1 que es lo que ocupa
el carbono y le restamos también 12.1
que es lo que ocupa el hidrógeno y eso
nos da exactamente 32 gramos de oxígeno
entonces nos quedamos con 32
gramos de oxígeno muy bien y ahí tenemos
cuántos gramos tenemos de cada sustancia
muy bien ahora tenemos que ver cuántos
moles de cada uno de estos elementos
está presente en cada mol del eugenio
quizás ya te hayas memorizado esto pero
si no de todos modos son datos que
puedes obtener en cualquier tabla
periódica por ejemplo el el carbono
tiene un peso atómico peso atómico y
cuando hablamos del peso atómico es en
realidad el promedio de las masas
atómicas de todos los isótopos del
carbono verdad ok entonces este es más o
menos el tiene un peso atómico
aproximado de 12 esto es lo que nos está
diciendo el peso atómico es que tiene 12
gramos por cada mol cada mol de carbono
tiene 12 gramos muy bien
ahora bien el hidrógeno también tiene
tiene un peso atómico una masa atómica
según según lo que estemos considerando
pero en esencia tiene más o menos
tiene un peso atómico de 1 esto nos está
diciendo que tiene un gramo por cada
molde de hidrógeno muy bien y por
supuesto hay más decimales pero vamos a
redondear lo para hacer todo este
problema mucho más sencillo y finalmente
el oxígeno tiene una una masa atómica o
peso atómico según si estamos trabajando
con el promedio de los isótopos o masa
atómica si estamos hablando de un
isótopo en particular tiene un peso
atómico de aproximadamente 16 lo que nos
dice que tiene 16 gramos por cada molde
de oxígeno muy bien entonces con esta
información que pueden obtener en una
tabla periódica ya podemos convertir
estos gramos que obtuvimos en moles muy
bien entonces cuántos moles tendríamos
de carbono dado que ya tenemos 120 punto
1 gramos de carbono vamos a ver
necesitamos multiplicar aquí por gramos
de carbono y arriba moles de carbono
cuantos moles tenemos por cada gramo
de carbono tenemos
por cada 12 gramos verdad entonces esto
simplemente nos queda 120 punto 1 entre
12 que eso es bastante fácil de resolver
verdad 120 punto 1 entre 12 es
aproximadamente 10 verdad 120 entre 12
es más o menos 10 y estos son moles de
carbono vamos a ver qué pasa con el
hidrógeno con el hidrógeno tenemos uno a
uno verdad es decir tenemos aquí un
molde de hidrógeno corresponde a un
molde de hidrógeno entonces los que no
quise decir un molde hidrógeno otra vez
quise decir que un molde hidrógeno
corresponde a un gramo de hidrógeno
verdad sí bueno el otro era era más que
más que obvio entonces si cancelamos los
gramos de hidrógeno simplemente nos
quedan 12.1 moles de hidrógeno bueno x 1
que esto es 12.1 moles de hidrógeno
verdad y todo esto es aproximado
y finalmente qué ocurre con el oxígeno
vamos a ver en el oxígeno cuántos gramos
de oxígeno tengo por cada molde oxígeno
entonces por cada molde oxígeno lo que
tenemos son 16 gramos muy bien entonces
si hacemos esta multiplicación los
gramos de oxígeno se cancelan y me queda
32 por 1 sobre 16 que esto es 2 verdad y
como todo esto lo estamos redondeando
esto es 2 moles de oxígeno entonces ya
tenemos aquí por ejemplo podríamos
todavía simplificar un poquito más
verdad para que quede ya en números
enteros vamos a redondear lo estos 12
moles de hidrógeno y entonces tenemos
exactamente cuál es nuestra fórmula
molecular tenemos 10 moles de carbono 12
moles de hidrógeno y 2 moles de oxígeno
entonces nuestra fórmula nuestra fórmula
molecular dice que tenemos 10 carbonos
tenemos
12 hidrógenos y tenemos finalmente 2
oxígenos muy bien y esta es la fórmula
molecular fórmula molecular ahora si
nosotros queremos obtener la fórmula
empírica simplemente tenemos que ver
cuál es la proporción más sencilla que
podemos obtener de esta misma fórmula y
si nos damos cuenta todos estos son
divisibles entre 2 verdad entonces
podemos dividir entre 2 y tendríamos que
nuestra fórmula empírica la fórmula
empírica
empírica corresponde a la proporción más
sencilla que podemos hacer por ejemplo
si dividimos entre 2 tenemos 5 carbonos
tendríamos 6 hidrógenos y pues si
dividimos 2 entre 2 nos queda un oxígeno
y como ven ya no podemos simplificarlo
más y esta es la fórmula empírica y con
esto hemos terminado